of the science illustrate paronto and he
had this fresh ground waiting wizard
with some showing that MIT star was re
and he will talk about relative results
or multiple protocols and we hopefully
get us some insights about this new
result as well thank you thanks Andres
good morning so thanks for coming to my
talk and thanks to the organizers for
setting up this wonderful workshop so
today I'm going to talk about multi
prove our protocols and there's there's
two main things that I'd like to convey
and in this talk and the next so the
first is is kind of a general theme and
which is that multi prove or protocols
are very useful lens on many different
topics in complexity theory cryptography
and and more and and this is sort of
like a shameless riff off of a theme
that I like very much which is um you
know the computational lens on the
sciences which I think comes from
Berkeley so and and the second thing
that I want to convey is more concrete
it's you know something called rigidity
or self testing and it's a very simple
but powerful tool okay so so let's start
with the the model what is a multi prove
or protocol okay
well the set up is this there there are
two devices you know there well think of
them as black boxes in this case
PowerPoint makes them blue but they're
you know you know nothing about them
they're completely opaque and the
question is what can the the P I which
stands for polynomial time investigator
obviously learn from these two devices
through classical interaction only
and these devices are described by
quantum mechanics we know that and they
can't signal to each other so you know
think of them the devices being put in
separate rooms and here are some things
that are a polynomial-time investigator
might wonder about you know the she
might wonder are these boxes performing
a quantum computation correctly are they
generating secure random bits or maybe
are they holding a ground state of a
local Hamiltonian or maybe more
ambitious questions such as are they
capable of solving the halting problem
or maybe there are they using infinite
dimensional entanglement so these are
rather bold questions and it turns out
amazingly all of these questions are
checkable are verifiable using multi
prove or protocols
so here's the the mental model that we
should try to have when thinking about
these protocols okay so we think of our
PII as a computationally limited
verifier it's she runs in polynomial
time she can only perform classical
computations and these devices we think
of them as provers okay they're more
computationally powerful than our
verifier and they're trying to convince
this sceptical verifier of some claim X
and some examples of this claim might be
maybe some integer as a product of two
primes this statement X could also be
the boxes are generating secure random
bits or maybe that a quantum circuits C
accepts with high probability
so these claims are something that you
know the the verifier is interested in
in determining but the verifier by
itself cannot maybe solve on its own so
instead the the verifier will perform an
interactive protocol with these two
provers these two devices to determine
if X is true and we'd like to you know
carry out protocols that satisfy two
properties one is completeness if this
claim X is indeed true then there should
be a way that these provers can convince
the the verifier of this fact with high
probability and the second property is
soundness if X is actually false then
there's nothing the provers can do to
convince this verifier
and you know if we were just you know
one thinking about this it's very useful
to sort of you know ascribe the
following goals of the provers and
verifier so this verifier wants to
verify X using the the fewest
assumptions and the provers you know
they want to convince the verifier of a
statement X even if it's not true and
the you know the goal is to design a
protocol that you know the verify can
still check the correctness or the truth
of X so so I mentioned this multi
proofer lens and at first sight you know
this multi prover model might seem very
abstract and maybe a little contrived
but multi proven protocols has allowed
us to learn many valuable lessons and in
each of these different areas
photography complexity theory
foundations of quantum mechanics and
also in terms of pure mathematics so you
know the the reason it's so useful is
because it's a really nice sandbox to
explore many different concepts you know
how they play with each other for
example you know how does quantum
entanglement interact with complexity
theory how does it interact with say
privacy and and say local Hamiltonians
and and it also connects to things that
don't have you know seemingly nothing to
do with devices or physics you know such
as the analysis or operator algebra so
so in this talk and and then the next
I'll you know it's sort of broken into
two parts in this this first hour I'll
talk about something sort of a simple
example of rigidity and show how as an
application it can be used to give a
very simple interactive proof for
quantum computation and this will sort
of illustrate a lot of the techniques
and ideas that go into thinking about
multi approver protocols and in the
second half I'll talk about some more
advanced examples of this rigidity
phenomenon
and show how it can lead to a
application to the complexity of MIP
star let's let's start with something
simple which is we would like to have
classical verification of eponymous just
quantum behavior so in some sense
multi proven protocols originated not
from computer science but actually you
know from physics and in the earliest
20th century
so in 1935 Einstein Podolsky and Rosen
you know asked the following question
they said if you had two boxes you know
they're separated far apart from each
other and these boxes are say behaving
according to the laws of quantum
mechanics and these boxes receive inputs
x and y ok and we assume that since the
boxes are separated you know this box
for example has no idea what this input
X is and this box has no idea what input
Y is the box has produced outputs a and
B and you know they ask can the input
and output behavior of these two boxes
be described by classical physics and
you know thirty years later Bell gave a
resounding answer to this question he
says no and sort of the modern
interpretation of this answer is is
through the multi prover protocol it's
very simple to describe and I'll
describe it through something called the
the Magic Square game and this is a very
simple game so so think of a three by
three grid of binary variables x1 up to
X 9 and these variables have to satisfy
the following six constraints so the the
parity of every row has to be 0 and the
parity of these first two columns have
to be 0 as well but if you add up these
three variables in the last column they
should sum up to 1
so it's very easy to see that there's no
way of choosing zeros and ones for these
variables to satisfy all of these
constraints this is not a satisfiable
constraint satisfaction problem and you
know so that's the first thing to notice
and we can sort of take this constraint
satisfaction problem and turn it into a
game with that we can play with these
two devices and the way we play this
game is to the first box we're going to
pick a random constraint okay so this
would corresponds to picking a random
row or a random column and so in this
case for example we're going to pick the
first column and give the first column
to this box so X 1 X 4 X 7 and to the
second box we're going to pick a random
variable in this constraint so in this
case X 4 and what we're going to ask
from these boxes is to give an
assignment of bits to each of the
variables that they received so this
first box should tell us what the
assignment you know anyone a 4 a 7 to
these variables should be and this
second box should just give us one bit
out and in this game you know they they
win this game if their answers satisfy
the following conditions which is that
you know this this box when it outputs
these 3 bits is just satisfy the
constraint in this case the sum of these
3 bits should be equal to 0 in this case
right because it corresponds to the
first column and there should also be a
consistency constraint which is that
when this box outputs this bit B it
should match a 4 right because that's
the variable that they haven't caught a
common okay so that's the game hopefully
make sense and I mentioned that this
constraint satisfaction problem was not
satisfiable so what does it mean about
this game so if these devices were
behaving classically you know you can
think of it as they're behaving
deterministically then there's no way
for them to satisfy both of these
constraint
all the time okay there is no winning
strategy that wins perfectly for these
two devices and so we you know you can
calculate that their maximum probability
of winning is that most seventeen or
eighteen
so something less than one why can't
they say zero so so if this box always
outputs zero then it's sort of a sudden
it's assigning zeros to all of these
variables in order for that that to
match this box this box also has to out
output zeros all the time but when it
for example receives this last column up
with zero zero zero it's not going to
satisfy the constraint that these bits
sum up to one so there's always going
you know there's always going to be a
constraint that's violated if they use a
deterministic strategy
yes yeah there's a type of there
yeah okay so so that's you know the
analysis of classical boxes but quantum
mechanics tells us there's some strange
behavior that can happen if these boxes
share a quantum entangled State so in
particular by sharing four entangled
qubits two on each side there's a
strategy for these devices to win this
Magic Square game to satisfy these
conditions with probability one so
there's some spooky behavior going on
and you know what is this this strategy
well it's it's not too difficult these
two devices can share two EPR pairs
right so an EPR pair is the maximally
entangled State on on two qubits two of
those and when you know for example when
this box receives the name of a variable
it's going to make a measurement on it's
two qubits according to what this 3x3
grid of measurement tells you so so for
example if this box gets x4 it's going
to measure it's two qubits using the
observable no identity tensor Sigma Z it
tames a bit and it reports that bit as
its assignment and when this box you
know gets the three variables it will
perform you know all the measurements
dictated by this column on its two
qubits and report all of the bits and
you can sort of run through the
calculation and it turns out that you
know performing the this quantum
strategy allows them to win this game
with probability 1 even though there's
no way to deterministic Li satisfy all
the constraints so there's some you know
spooky behavior going on and importantly
these two devices you know even though
they're sharing quantum entanglement
they you know aren't allowed to you know
signals to to just
and okay so so what this gives us is an
experimental test for non classical
physics right this Magic Square game and
many other types of games like it are
called Bell tests and you know so one
way you can run this experiment as well
you just have these two devices and you
just play this Magic Square game with
them and if the devices are consistently
winning this game this gives you strong
evidence that their behavior cannot be
described by classical physics and in
fact this is something that has been
carried out experimentally many times
over the years this was a picture of you
know the layout of a Bell test that that
was running you know a few years ago in
other words here's here's the the two
boxes a and B and this is the verifier
that sends the two questions to these
okay so so that's that's very cool
but there's something stronger that we
can say which is that you know if you
assume that these devices are just
properly described by quantum mechanics
then there's essentially only a unique
quantum strategy for them to win this
particular game with probability one and
this is what I call rigidity so here's a
theorem so if you have you know these
two devices they share some entangled
States i and they're performing some
measurements inside and with the state
and measurements they're winning this
game with probability one then in fact
there's a local change of basis there's
a way in which you know you can choose a
reference frame for each of these two
devices where under that basis change
this state looks like two copies of the
EPR pair and the the measurements that
they're making are the ones that I wrote
down in the previous slide they're
performing these Polly X and Z
measurements on these EPR pairs so in
there in some sense there's nothing else
that they can be doing other than maybe
just choosing a different
basis for you know reference frame for
therefore the measurement was there
something special about the exact
setting of you know zero zero zero zero
zero one for the parodies or any kind of
parodies you want would also work the
question not sure if all possible
settings I don't think all possible
settings works but for example I had you
know five zeros and one one
you can also do you know three zeros on
the columns and ones on the bottom
that's there's some freedom there
right so so you know you you play this
test with the devices not only you know
if they're winning with probability what
not only do you know that they're
behaving non classically but in fact
they must be using this specific quantum
strategy
and you know this is it's somewhat
simple but a very powerful idea it gives
us what's you know we call a classically
shun quantum systems okay and you know
so I said this phenomena is called
rigidity right the game is somehow rigid
it's it's forced into behaving a certain
quantum way and you know and the
literature it's also called self testing
and these rigidity properties of
protocols like magic Square and and
other games like the CSS hrgh see
they're at the heart of many quantum
multi prover protocols and in fact
advances in in developing more rich
rigidity phenomenon leads to advances in
design protocols war dance protocols
so so you know testing for you know
certifying to qubits is nice you know
you can play this game you know these
devices are are sharing two cubits of
entanglement but what if you wanted to
certify many more cubits of entanglement
so you know a natural idea is if you
wanted to certify n qubits of
entanglement well why not play many
copies of this magic square game right
so you can play an independent instances
of magic square game with these two
boxes and it turns out you can prove
that this repeated game also certifies
entanglement between the two devices and
in fact it's going to certify that you
know the devices have 2n EPR pair shared
between them and the measurements that
they're making are really going to be a
tensor product of these poly X and poly
Z's if you just see that they're winning
with probability 1 minus epsilon which
is indistinguishable from this depending
how off you're trying it then how much
do you know about and that's a great
question so it's a question of how so
the question is you know suppose that
you know how can you ever tell that
these devices are winning with
probability 1 you can only sort of test
that they're winning with probability
close to 1 what can you guarantee so if
they're winning with probability 1 minus
epsilon then their strategy must be you
know epsilon times n close to this
optimal strategy so this is something
I'll get so there's some robustness
statement the robustness of this
particular game is not so great and
actually this is something of
to later but there is something you can
say in the one-
so good so so you know we using this the
simple game we have a way of testing for
for lots of entanglement between these
two devices and in fact we can say
precisely what that entanglement is
so that was a test for you know
classical verification of some quantum
behavior just you know having a tangle
meant but we can lift this to a
classical verification of quantum
computations in the multi provers
setting
this is a long-standing problem which is
you know if you build a quantum computer
can it efficiently prove its correctness
to a classical verifier before 2012 the
best results used semi-classical
verifiers way we have interactive
protocols where a verifier could
determine whether some devices were
performing a quantum computation
correctly but they always relied on the
verifier having some small quanis get
into it but what if you wanted just a
purely classical verifier in 2012
Ben Faulk and mesh have this beautiful
results which is turns out you you can
do this you can't accomplish this in in
the multi prove or setting they gave a
classical multi proved a protocol for
for computations and you know some years
later before Allah came up with a
protocol that used only one proven the
you know the first time that we were
able to have a purely classical verifier
was wasn't 2012
so this results which I'll call our UV
have any beautiful ideas it introduced
you know rigidity for testing for many
qubits it analyzed the sequential CH SH
game and it sort of exploited a lot of
the techniques that we use very often in
in the analysis of multi proven
protocols today for example interleaving
rigidity tests with tests for
computation and combining rigidity with
a measurement based computation and
putting all these ideas together you
know you're able to come up with a
protocol for for certifying quantum
computations it's just a classical very
and it's it's quite a tour de force you
know it's a it's a hundred pages you
know the protocol itself is you know
it's it's efficient but you know in
order to certify a tea gate circuit you
the prover needs to run for T to the
eight thousand time so totally not
practical and it has many rounds of
interaction but it's it's still the
first
and I won't explain you know how are you
be works but I'll explain it's sort of a
simplification which is due to Alex
Carrillo who's sitting right there and
it's it's a verification protocol it's a
multi prove er and it's it's much
simpler than than ruv it's distilled
down to 20 pages it's a one round
protocol and you know maybe more
importantly I can describe it to you in
this talk and but it you know explaining
the protocol will sort of illustrate a
lot of the ideas that are UV pioneered
so so here's the set up you know we have
our polynomial time investigator and
she's wondering there's some circuit I'm
really interested in this quantum
circuit I don't have a quantum computer
but I'm wondering if I ran this on a
quantum computer and I measured the
first qubit of the circuit does it
measure to one with high probability
does this circuit itself so it can't do
it itself so instead it talks to these
two quantum devices these provers are
trying to prove that the output of the
circuit is one with high probability
even if it isn't and if it isn't you
know hopefully the verifier can catch
this so again we have to have a protocol
that satisfies completeness is the
circuit except with high probability
then the prover should be able to
convince the verifier of this case
otherwise the verifier should reach
and also you know very importantly we're
interested in prove our fishin see right
we want these boxes to be implementable
in the real world so loot
you know whatever they're doing to to
run this protocol to convince this
verifier of this fact it should be able
to do this in in quantum polynomial time
so to to do this lets you know kind of
think about an easier setting right
actually back to the semi-classical
setting so let's imagine that our
verifier here has a trusted measurement
device so it's it's a device that can
receive quantum states and it takes as
an input and untrusted states i okay we
know nothing about sy but the the
verifier can command this device to
perform measurements of each qubit in
either the X or Z basis and the the
verifier here trusts this device to do
that properly and you know when it
measures it reports the measurement
outcomes back to the verifier so you
know this seems like kind of a simple
device it's not doing much is just
making single qubit Nations but this is
enough for the verifier to check
arbitrary bqp computations
and you know what's the idea behind this
well it's its uses something called the
the Fineman kitaev circuit - hamiltonian
construction which is an efficient
mapping from a quantum circuit C to a
local hamiltonian h that essentially
encodes the the computation so the
ground state of this hamiltonian h is
some mystery state this will be some
state side that's a superposition over
all intermediate stages of this
computation of the circuit so if the
circuit has size teeth then overall
times T we have the state of the circuit
at that time that's the going to be the
ground state of this Hamiltonian
and it turns out that there are circuit
to Hamiltonian constructions where this
these Hamiltonians have a very nice form
it turns out that with without loss of
generality we can assume that each of
these Hamiltonian terms are tensor
products of X and Z measurements
all right and what do we know about this
circuit to Hamiltonian transformation
suppose the the output of this circuit
is one with let's say probability one
then this history state that I just
described has zero energy it's a zero
energy state of this on the other hand
if the circuit accepts the probability
less than one thirds then if you look at
the average energy of this of any state
actually with respect to this
Hamiltonian it's at least one over poly
n where n is the the number of qubits in
this circuit in other words the minimum
eigen value of this Hamiltonian is is at
least one over polynomial so there's a
gap in the the minimum eigen values
either 0 or or something separated from
zero
but in fact we're you know we can boost
this minimum eigen value to something
noticeable 1/2 and this uses some a
simple hamiltonian amplification trick
this results in a non-local Hamiltonian
but that's okay we're not so worried
about that
and this non-local Hamiltonian will
still only be you know polynomial e
bigger than the original Hamilton so
this is the guarantee that we have about
this Hamiltonian
okay so let's go back to this trusted
measurement setup so here's the
measurement protocol to verify a
computation so this this verifier knows
the circuit it's going to compute this
Hamiltonian from the circuit and this
trusted measurement device gets some
state you know maybe it's the ground
state maybe it's some other state and
the verify will command this device to
measure a random hamiltonian termination
and it measures the state and it reports
the measurement outcomes and the
verifier will accept if the outcomes
correspond to the kernel of this random
term so so why is this a good
verification protocol so if we're in the
yes case meaning that this original
circuit accepted with probability 1 then
by providing a history state of this
computation to this trust and
measurement device it will always report
that this state is you know in the
kernel of of this term and so this
verify will always accept whereas in the
no case any state sign us provided to
this trusted measurement device is
always going to measure with some
nonzero energy probability and the
verify we would reject with probability
at least 1/2 so that just comes from the
guarantees of what our Hamiltonian gives
oh yeah good so yeah it's a sum of the H
eyes and the guarantee here is that if
we pick a random term and measure the
energy yeah
and it's going to have energy at least
half
need to say why 1/3 is the cutoff to
make this 1/3 is somewhat arbitrary as
long it's it's separated from one by
some noticeable
okay so you know assuming our verify has
this nice measurement device it can
verify bgp computations but you know we
you know in this multi prove we're
setting we don't have a trusted
measurement device so so what can we do
well we're going to use rigidity to our
advantage so we're going to what this
now purely classical verifier is going
to do it's gonna force one of these
provers to act as a trusted measurement
device and in this you know an Alexes
protocol it's very simple with
probability 1/2 the verifier performs a
rigidity test it's gonna perform play
these n magic square games like i
described before and you know when you
when you play this game and you know
these devices pass with high probability
what can you guarantee about these
devices well firstly they must share
many EPR pairs and they're performing
these x and z measurements as
so that's one half the test the other
half is the verifier performs an energy
test right now that we know one of the
devices is a trusted measurement device
we can get it to to measure a state with
a basis choice of our choosing and in
this energy test what this other prove
er is going to do this prove or a it's
going to teleport a states I hopefully
the ground state to prove our B and the
verifier is going to ask prove or B to
measure this
so so let me say some more details about
this this energy test well the the
verifier is first going to pick some
number of EPR pairs so given some
parameters here so n is the the number
of qubits of our our ground state and
we're going to pick capital n to be
larger than little n so I think it is it
n square so the the verifier is going to
pick
some subset of little and EPR pairs
and then it's going to tell proof or a
to teleport some states I threw these
EPR pairs to prove ur B and if you
remember when you perform quantum
teleportation there's a measurement
outcome okay that corresponds to poly
errors on the the resulting teleported
state so we call those teleportation
keys and this prove ur will report the
teleportation keys to the the verifier
at least you know the that's what the
verifier is hoping we don't actually
know what prove ur a is doing it could
you know just ran you know completely
random stream K of that has nothing to
do with teleportation but it's going to
report some key k and ideally these keys
should indicate the x and z errors on on
each of the telluric units
so in that case some teleportation
happens and the state that's sitting on
provably side is going to be the state
side with these errors
okay so so now the verifier is going to
turn to prove or be and it's going to
pick a random hamiltonian term each I
it's going to pick a random basis string
our that's just X's and Z's for each of
the big n EPR pairs
and it's going to hide this Hamiltonian
term a chai which we can assume is just
specifying X and Z measurements into
this random string are okay so for
example let's imagine that a chai is you
know saying we want to perform
measurement Sigma X Sigma Z Sigma Z then
in wherever this random subset s is
indicating it's going to hide a chai
into those those locations
so let's you know only prove ur a knows
the subset s prove or B has no idea
then the verifier is gonna tell approver
be to measure all of the TPR pairs all
capital end of its EPR pairs using this
basis are and report the measurement
outcomes and ideally the measurement
outcomes when you restrict to this
random subset s it should correspond to
measuring this you know this model is
teleport a state with this Hamiltonian
and this verifier can decode this
measurement using the keys K and except
if the outcomes correspond to again the
the kernel of H I so essentially what
the verifier is done is is asked this
prove ER to measure the states I using
this H I so all right you know describe
why it works any questions about what
some redundancy like the Z's are not
going to change the energy seem like Z
operators we change the energy so it
depends if the Hamiltonian you know say
for this qubit if the Hamiltonian
then I think the Z would cause a bit
flip he says that there was a seer then
or if I should flip the the bit the
measurement oh I guess when you commute
them through there'll be some Z's left
that don't matter but before commuting
it matters okay round this is this means
a message from the vampires to the
prover and so I started described in a
two step process first talking to prove
red then talking to prove or be all of
it can be done simultaneously
so why does this this work because let's
think about the yes case let's say that
the circuit C actually accepted with
probability one well then then there
really is some ground state this history
state with zero energy and you know we
know that the prover beeper forms this
measurement protocol honestly you know
or you know if it prove you know
performs this measure costly then the
bear file will always accept that's
that's easy to see
let's let's you know analyzing converse
to pros the provers succeed with
probability 1 minus epsilon so this is
well then since it's performing to test
with probably ID 1/2 then it must be the
provers must pass each test with
probability at least 1 minus 2 epsilon
so think about song is very small so in
particular it passes this rigidity test
and what do we know about prove RB well
it must be some polynomial in n times
epsilon close to this ideal trusted
measurement device
and also the shared state is is close to
being a tensor product of EPR pairs
here's the key fact prove RB cannot tell
the difference between a rigidity and
energy test that's very important right
it shouldn't be able to know if you know
it's supposed to be verifying this
computation or trying to pass these and
Magic Square games so if it wants if
this proved RB wants to do well then it
has to behave the same in both so so we
know that if it passes the rigidity test
proved Irby must be a trusted measurer
tests okay so now we have a foothold now
when we go to this energy test
well prove ur a knows which tests it's
playing right it's either playing the
Magic Square games or it's being told to
teleport something we can easily
distinguish well that's okay no matter
what prove ur a is doing you want to
report some keys so fix a key K there's
some you know residual state of the
entire system
we know that poober b is passing this
trusted measurement protocol with high
probability that's my assumption and
what this tells us is that this
hamiltonian h actually has a ground
energy that's close to zero I give you
this promise on this is that energy was
either zero or at least a half okay so
it actually must be zero what this means
is that this circuit must accept with
probability 1
so you know putting everything together
this is you know the completeness we we
determined it it does except there's a
verifier will always accept the circuit
does not accept the probability with
probability then then no matter what the
provers do then the verifier will reject
with inverse polynomial probability but
you know there's a way to amplify it so
that all provers strategies are rejected
with
and the proofer complexity is this
polynomial and the size of the circular
wants to verify around this one
my feet grows with the depth of the
circuit - right because the number of
Hamiltonian comes in the math mapping
grows with the depth right there's
another hidden cost in this so here
we're yeah we're not very careful we
actually we just assumed each layer has
only one gate so but if you have a real
circuit with lots of multi qubit
operations this is gonna grow very
rapidly that's right it's it's still not
practical you know what is the
polynomial here it's it's better than
you know T to the 8,000 it's like think
it's more like T cubed or something it
affects the locality of derivative but
not how many terms you have like it's
how big they are but I think I'll agree
with that but the depth of the circuit
also increases the number of terms
because the clock it's a trivial are
mockolate
they're gonna have our gates at least
enough
that question previously you've made a
comment about the magic square game not
having good for bust this properties I
was where if you could expand on that
because you were showing some one minus
epsilon 1 minus 2 epsilon polygamist
yeah yeah that's a good thing too
in order for this closeness guarantee to
trivial this epsilon has to be very
small has to be you know smaller than
one over n at least but n is you know
the size of this computation so in order
to get any guarantees we're actually
demanding that these two devices pass
this test with probability very very
close to one otherwise we we can't say
anything so you know in terms of
practical parameters it's not very
useful but this is just sort of to
illustrate how using this imagine you
know this rigidity verify the
computation say in polynomial time
but of course you might want to replace
this with a more robust rigidity test
where the closeness parameter hopefully
should not depend on that's what I'll
talk about in there so this was by using
the moment could have construction a
tennis or thing that could transform
measurements could you use any
representation on the position adjust
this so this is yeah this was a very
generic argument we didn't need that it
was this particular finding can tie up
construction in fact this is a very
generic protocol for verifying ground
states of X and V so that good somebody
came out much better much machinery than
kosis and have a clue inside what
ultimately understanding the previous
game we have a trusted measurement
device
yes
the reason being like we're appealing to
the fact that the trusted protocol works
so we want to simulate it and what we
really want to do is we want to measure
the energy of this Hamiltonian we could
only do that if it's in the same
language there's also X in V if they
were you know other types of
measurements then it's not immediately
clear how you would ask these provers to
perform those measurements yeah so I
thought that that connected somehow to
the he needed some special additional
with each of the H items they were
different form than you rigidity test
they tested for those types of
measurements
so hopefully I got your protocol so just
to recap this you know this first part
this first talk these multi approver
protocols are you know they're very
useful framework to study complex
quantum systems one being the state of a
quantum computation and really the the
key thing that drove why you know Alex's
protocol works and why many of these
protocols work is because rigidity we
were able to establish a classical leash
on these quantum systems we can force
them to do what we want and entrust
their
certifying epr pairs and XE measurements
you know it's by itself doesn't seem
like much but it turns out it's enough
to verify arbitrary bqp computations and
in the next talk I'll I'll talk about
more advanced rigidus or the frontier of
what we can prove a rigidity of
protocols the complexity of
so that's it for this first just to
follow up on a previous discussion this
is know that that rigid rigidity for the
magic square name like that's possible
it seems like it's just using a single
triangle yeah I don't know I don't know
I don't think we know whether it's the
best possible you know potentially
possible that this whole with without
the end
the questions if I made the the first is
this is a fully adversarial scenario and
for practical experimental applications
most experiments aren't terribly
adversarial what can you say about such
situations so probably much more I mean
certainly we've we've done this analysis
in the adversarial setting and I guess
first it's remarkable how much we can
say in such a setting but yeah you know
and all the parameters are not
practically useful so I think it's a
very interesting question to try to and
in more assumptions may be more
reasonable assumptions about the device
and in such multi-crew protocols to try
to establish stronger guarantees about
characterizing the system you have in
your lab
yeah I don't know people actually looked
into using self-testing to characterize
city misc devices or anything but I
think that's the second thing I was
thinking is this reduction is very
reminiscent of the proof of security of
quantum key distribution because there's
testing of devices on that case to
ensure that you have the EPR pairs in
the you know CSS codes version of the
protocol between the sender and the
receiver and the need to Edward 91 or
something and in the case of qkd there's
a beautiful reduction when using CSS
codes to make it practically realizable
I can see some codes must be hiding
around here if you employed codes
instead of the magic square game Mike
you actually be able to simplify some of
these measurements get rid of memories
and reduce it to something more
practically realizable familiar with
this
so this is a data question other local
bands know for how many rounds of
authentication you to prove your M cubed
security gates so this is only a single
round do you mean oh that's a great
question
you think maybe just to test for a sighs
you know tea circuit you would need a
these tea bits but turns out I guess
given the the results of the next talk
say if you can specify your circuit very
succinctly then you don't need as
it's a communication
so regarding the round question I
understand the protocol right the
verifier sends a message to the prover a
ver ver responds and then that response
is used in a message right so that's not
necessary it's it can all be done
simultaneously so the only message from
approver today is what these keys are
these teleportation keys and they're
only used at the end of the protocol to
decode the measurement results of
letting just depends on s
in multi Kreuger protocols as the
strength come from having to prove errs
or you get something more from having
more than two you're saying if you three
provers say could you do more yeah
that's so certainly for example you know
by playing and say like a jersey game
which is like a tripartite three players
you can certify that the three boxes
share the ghz state that's something
that's sort of native to the three party
setting well if you can do anything more
in terms of certifying quantum
computation as well I guess to prove
errs is enough
yes I don't you know have too many
examples we're having more parties
necessarily it helped a communication
right if you have four then you can do a
vlog good communication I think but by
there is a pattern in tomorrow like this
using this game version of quantum PCP I
think you can do that to delegate
confrontation with four approvers analog
communication in certain cases having
more approvers helps you design
[Applause]